thomas tomber 40 j'aimerais qu'on fasse
un petit coucou ouais à vos enfants
soient à ce gentil je pense qu'ils nous
regardent aller devant la caméra sont là
la caméra là bas il fonctionne avec tous
syrie le faux confort des enfants qui
peux pas le blairer
c'est vrai que c'est pour ça que j'ai
alors jacques grande si je vous dis ne
peux pas me tenir et chaque fois qu'elle
me voit de me taper c'est un truc de ouf
et pour ça que je suis devenir angelina
voilà le thème la chérir la mecque bien
une vidéo avec angelina dans la canal
factory où elle me court après pour me
taper
non elle ne peut pas pourquoi je sais
pas non à croire que c'est la fille de
quelqu'un d'autre
non on va arrêter choses en place
maintenant je suis sûr que ce soir il ya
de l'espoir pour leur entraîneur et ça
fait plaisir grâce très fort en tout cas